I have to expose this point right now I
spoke to this brother after the Jubilee
debate and then I was speaking to him
and I asked him I was like bro you're
not really an ex-muslim are you you said
your dad was a Jew so you have Jew half
you're a Christian I'm wondering where
is his Muslim background I I I literally
asked him I was like you're not really
Muslim are you he looked me dead in the
eyes and he's like no I'm not
and he didn't finish right there he said
I told them that I wasn't but they gave
me the role anyway
[Music]
welcome back to the three Muslims I know
it's been a while about we're good to be
back just a quick disclaimer Jubilee
they posted the video unfortunately it
was not uncut and raw so we are going to
be responding to a lot of the things
that people have been commenting about
and before we go in check the timestamps
in the description box inshallah for
specific parts to fast forward
me would be like the issue of the hijab
which I know a lot of people will
counter so the Quran says women have to
cover the heimar to cover up so that
they don't tempt um the men and then I
will say the Quran does technically say
men's hijab is their gaze the male gaze
and I just that just seems a little
silly to me beyond that like in the
Quran how men can have up to four wives
or women can't it's like I or I in the
Islamic school I want to say the ideazan
the call to prayer all the boys in my
class they're like we're going to do the
call to prayer for this Friday
um I'm ineligible because I'm a woman
apparently can't do the Azan I can't do
the call to prayer so just those I would
say are my core on specific examples and
they're like well this is to protect
women I don't see that at all yeah so
there's a lot of different points that
you brought up the first one being the
hijab which the woman is obligated to
wear and you talked about how the men
have to lower their gaze which is 100
right the women also have to lower their
gaze and the men actually have their own
hijab so the men have their own parts of
their body that needs to be covered as
well so obviously men and women were
created both physically different and
psychologically all different types of
they're different in every single way
there's different parts of the body that
need to be covered because men are
attracted to different things when it
attracted to different things and it's
to protect both sides second thing that
you brought up I believe you mentioned
the you not being able to make the call
to prayer once again that's in order to
protect the woman just because men can
also be attracted to the voice of women
so that's the reason that that's not
allowed and I completely understand that
you being a young child that's something
that you wanted to do and I mean
pre-puberty um in your household when
you're with your family that's something
that you should feel free to practice
make the call to prayer do that in front
of your father your brothers your uncles
it doesn't matter it doesn't need to be
in front of the whole entire mosque so
there may be things that you felt
because you were a woman you were being
limited to but there's a benefit behind
it so it's about looking into that I
think this is bringing up an important
important point of contention here with
all the things that you're saying and
you keep bringing up that men and women
are fundamentally different where is
that coming from where's work coming
from when you say those things when I
say what men and women are fundamentally
different in these very specific ways
men are attracted to a woman's voice
okay so scientifically men and women are
different so if you were just looking at
someone with men and I look at a woman
I'm pretty sure I would see some
differences as well as just
scientifically biologically emotionally
psychologically there's been studies
because everyone starts to question you
being able to change your sex and be
able to change your gender but you were
created it as a certain sex for a reason
and I would so that's my point of
contention here there's nothing there's
nothing for me there when you say that I
was created for a specific purpose and a
woman was created for a specific purpose
I would disagree completely why can't I
fulfill those other purposes when you
start slowly building upon these layers
these layers of like roles that that
prescriptive prescriptive roles that
starts to create a system of Oppression
but Allah actually says
like there's no compulsion in religion
So when you say that why can't I do XYZ
like why can't I do the other role for
example right these are things that
because Allah expects you to these are
the things best for you but it's not
that you can't do these things but when
you say it's best for me
the problem is there's always going to
be an existential threat I think it's
best for you because it's what's best
for society so everything that Allah
puts in place for us that we believe God
the reason that we have these specific
if you want to say roles because men
complement women in a certain way and
women complement women in a circle but
what I'm saying is he's not sick let me
explain myself all right very easy way
to understand that I'll use her point
right so you mentioned that for example
why can you not marry four husbands and
why can't I marry four wives right these
things have less to do with equality or
worthiness in the eyes of Allah and just
individual sex differences for example
if I have four wives right I can
impregnate all of them and we'll all
know who the father is and who the
mother is if you for example in this
scenario you have four husbands we won't
actually know who the father is and also
why is that important why would that
happen and how does that make men and
women equal in the Isis
bro what that what's wrong with this
Taha guy what's up with this dude I just
I just want to ask ask him bro did she
text you back because okay all jokes
aside I think that an army if you don't
mind putting it back in the normal
orientation
this is this is all because of a product
of the modern day feminist lens where
it's under this pretense that men and
women have to be the same they are equal
so anytime that you have anything that
contents or challenges that status quo
it's always going to seem something that
seems oppressive or barbaric so all of
these people are under the the notion of
this liberal mindset this postmodern
mindset that men and women have to be
equal in every single way possible now
Allah says in the Quran that a man is
not better than a woman and a woman is
not better than a man except in terms of
taqwa or piety or God Consciousness so
we know that they hold the same value in
the eyes of Allah with all other
variables being the same but they do
have differences as Jad said and these
inherent differences in I guess genetics
or in an environment or just in roles
they help shape a better Society I think
that's Undisputed I think anyone that
challenges that
let's go bro
and like in regards to the event thing
or obviously that's just one example
that she was using
basically like there's roles in our
religion there is roles for men and
there's roles for women then the person
who's giving that identity that is a
role for a man why is that a role for a
man because the men are the the ones
that are supposed to be praying at the
massaged now
what a lot of people don't know women
get the same reward
um that the men get by going to the
Masjid and all that ever that they have
to do to go to the Masjid and to get
that reward they want to get the exact
same reward that the men get by going
that they get of going to the Masjid by
praying at home now I want us to imagine
if the tables were switched here right
let's imagine that the men they would
get the same reward as the woman the
woman had to go to the Masjid but the
men if they stayed home they would get
the same reward imagine how much
everyone would be like oh my God that's
so unfair towards the towards the um the
woman
but no the woman get to stay at home and
they get to reap the rewards that the
man has to go to the measure to get so
why don't we bring that up you know what
I'm saying it's like it's very it's just
very selective it's not it's not a good
point
um and I wouldn't if it were obviously
when you look at it in hindsight there's
obviously things that you would say
differently I don't think I would use
the
because I had never even thought about
the like
a woman having to like are wanting to to
give the event
um that's why I brought up the like the
attraction obviously that's still a
thing but that's not like the primary
the primary reason
um so that's there's a lot there's a lot
of practicality into like imagine a
woman's pregnant bro she has to go to
the Masjid at 4am for Fajr Avon like
that's impractical a woman can't pray
for a quarter of the month I.E a quote
of her life most of it right so for her
to go to the Masjid and be expected to
do that I don't think it's fair I think
it's it's oppressive if anything it's
it's pushing her beyond what is easy and
reasonable for her because Allah has
revealed Islam to not make our lives
harder but easier so it would kind of be
hypothetical to expect women to fulfill
roles that are a little bit outside what
they deem reasonable now whether you can
or can't is not the main contention of
this point it's should we or should we
not from a societal point of view
and like something I want to address in
the comments obviously you're not seeing
it right now but you noticed everyone
you're going to notice it a lot in this
video that when I'm speaking with what's
your name Janet Janet yeah when I'm
speaking to Janet
um obviously I'm not looking directly at
her
um obviously because I'm trying to I'm
trying to lower my gaze so if you look
at the comment section of the video
already it's like oh my God he can't
even look at these people in the eyes
when he wants to talk to them no I
actually say it in the video that it's a
part of what we have to do is to lower
our gaze and um that's and if you notice
that when I'm talking to the men
um in the video then I actually look
them in their eye and have a
conversation but when it comes to
speaking with with woman I'm always
obviously we're supposed to lower our
gaze so I want to make sure that people
understand the reason for that not
because I'm scared to look at someone in
their eyes Never Scared them I have to
add the truth by my side so I'm like I'm
scared of and sisters he's single too
but before we go back into it quick
quick disclaimer right here for everyone
watching the brothers and sisters that
we had a decent experience with Jubilee
we're not here to kind of talk about on
them or anything but understand Jubilee
has rights to their content they are
their own creators and platform so they
are not going to air everything that we
had right so Chad me and you we were
there for like three four hours for the
whole recording but they trimmed it down
and cut it down into what like 40
minutes so there's a lot that I said and
Judd said and a lot of responses that we
had and a lot of rebuttals that they
completely omitted from that so
inshallah this video will serve as a
means of answering these questions
because a lot of the times
these separate external media they have
their own agenda now we're not saying
Jubilee has their own agenda because
again the whole point of this is Middle
Ground so all we could do is trust that
they will show both sides but there were
a lot of things Unfortunately they cut
out so that's what we want to talk about
today yeah and something else because
obviously alhamdulillah this is my
second time and um definitely my last
um so there was a couple differences in
terms of just the experience overall
with the first one um the director I
won't say her name but she was actually
the director for both but in the first
one she was the only one and she was the
one directing us and everything in the
second one she had an assistant who did
all the talking and she actually didn't
say anything this whole entire time now
the first in the first video that I was
in they allowed they allowed us to speak
freely
um she barely intervened she would
always say like please let this person
speak because they haven't said anything
or something like that but it was barely
like she was actually letting us have
like a like a conversation if you notice
in this video compared to the last one
there was a lot more interruptions in
this video
um there's a lot more just commotion it
seems a lot more argumentative
um than the in the first video that I
was in now the reason the being in
Fayette can
um agree to this or like confirm this
she one of the workers at Jubilee
literally came up to both sides and told
us that the second you disagree with
something I need you guys to jump on it
and don't let them finish like I need
you guys to interrupt them so when they
walked up to us and told us that I'm
like I'm like how are we going to have a
productive conversation if the second
that I'm not letting them get their
thoughts across I need to hear what they
have to say and this way that when I
speak they're giving me the respect so
that they can hear what I have to say
that's why when you notice if you when
you're watching the video every time
they're speaking me and Fayette and the
other people we're we're listening to
them and you'll I only one time and
that's the part of course that they put
as the introduction to the video but one
time that I actually get frustrated and
I cut them off but that was just one
time in the entire video if you look at
them when they're speaking and the whole
entire time or being respectful and
we're listening to what they have to say
but the second I speak they all jump in
and they all interrupt and they don't
let me they like half the time more than
half the time I wasn't even able to get
my complete thought out so it was just
really frustrating in the fact that it
was being they were being told but both
sides were being told to do that we just
didn't interrupt them while they're
speaking because that's just not our
nature I'm not it's just not not natural
to me to to interrupt someone while
they're mid-sentence
so yeah yeah
and I I think it really goes to show
that Jubilee is not always a place to
have enlightening discussions and to
show different perspectives on a certain
topic it's mainly an entertainment
Channel that's why people watch it
because it's entertaining and whatever
um but you'll see a lot of the time when
it comes to arguments against this other
people in the video or people in the
comments they're always shallow
arguments just veiled with some liberal
mindset like why can't I call the Adan
why do you need to call the event why is
it why is it calling it then something
that's so important to you or are you
just like are you just picking that
because you know something you're not
allowed to do
like as a man I can't sit on my bum all
day and be cared for by my wife does
that mean I should go and cry about it
all of a sudden like why is you in this
liberal Society are actually forced to
go out and work do you complain and cry
about that or do you pretend you're
liberated because you're taught that
it's something that's liberated and that
Taha guy like this goes to show how
incredulous these people are
what do you mean men and women are not
exactly the same in every single way
biologically psychologically and
otherwise it's like bro she can get
pregnant I can't
like it's so clear if they are not even
willing to accept that fundamental
premise you can't have a discussion with
these people
that's why you see these things coming
to like
um imagine you're a woman doing the then
and once a week or once a month for a
week you just can't do it five prayers a
day for like five days straight 25
prayers that you can't do the event for
just because you're on your period like
listen and let's let's take it a step
further these things are so practical
they're so practical a man is oh all day
working and whatever so the very fact
that he's already outside of the house
makes him more eligible to do the other
than having to go to to do the event
like there are so many ways you could
look at it to to understand the
practicality behind it at the very like
on the most fundamental level even if it
was just because women should stay home
and men should be the ones to go out and
work and all whatever so what why is
that why do you have a problem with this
all you're saying is I live a liberal
life this is not a liberal life and
you're crying about it like we have our
tradition you have your tradition you
don't see me crying about your tradition
so what gives you the right to
interrogate me about mine interrogate us
about our tradition
and I wanted to add in that was a
beautiful Point bro it reminds me of
this point that the nekabi sister on our
team her name is harmony she brought up
this point that it's not about why can't
we do these things but you got to
question why do you have an issue with
that why are you asking that question in
the first place it's because we live in
a society that kind of breeds this this
almost this androgynous State between
men and women so before we jump back
into this I do want to quickly note this
on polygyny because a lot of you know
we're assuming we can't just assume
Muslims are watching this do you know
what I mean so there's a lot of
non-muslims that are watching this and
they're kind of like why can't a man
marry you know four women and why can't
a woman not number one I want you to
understand that polygeny is not
something that Islam started polygeny is
something that has always been there men
have always had multiple partners and
perhaps women also did Islam is actually
the first religion to come down and
limit it to four wives so let's get that
clear there's no limitation to a number
of wives until Islam came and this is
for obvious reasons you know more men
die in war more men die in battle more
men even today work dangerous jobs
there's infant mortalities higher in
little boys than little girls across the
board look at the U.S population of men
and women there's always going to be
more men than women
and Allah has made it permissible if you
can take care of them and be responsible
for them and take accountability for
them that you can marry them however if
a woman has multiple partners because I
know all the sister's going to wonder
like why can I not have four husbands
number one it's not practical if you
have four husbands you want to marry uh
four men you want to have kids with all
of them nine months each bro you're
gonna be spending like most of your life
just struggling let's get that clear
number one number two we don't know who
the father is Right Studies have shown
today that one of the biggest
determinants in childhood delinquency
success in school drug use alcohol use
uh mental health it's knowing who your
father and mother are it's that lineage
it's Assurance of that so if one man
gets four women pregnant we all know who
the father is that one man and we all
know who the mother is but if roles will
reverse we don't know do you get what I
mean so Islam is a complete way of life
it's not just our religion it's not just
an ideology so that's why Allah has
thought about all the different aspects
of how we would live our life and he
makes no mistakes
yeah that's an amazing point and just to
just to piggyback off of that Islam as
you mentioned is a full system anytime
you take anything in isolation it's
gonna seem stupid like imagine I took a
car with just two wheels in the trunk
you're gonna be like the heck is the
point of that two wheels and like what
are you gonna do with that thing it's
not until you have a full car that you
understand the use of the wheels the
steering wheel the engine the trunk the
seats all of that the seat belt even
something as small as that imagine I had
two wheels on the seat belt you're like
yo what am I going to do with this Islam
is a full system so you can't just look
at the fact that a man can marry up to
four women and a woman cannot marry more
than one man and oh while we're so
oppressed you know how could God do this
to us think about the fact
that a man has to take care of a woman
can you imagine one woman being taken
care of by four guys while there are
other women who are still looking to get
married can you imagine one woman
magneted by one of her three husbands
everyone else having to wait and she
only wants two kids so then one guy if
he's really lucky gets two kids and two
guys if they're somewhat lucky get one
each like it in every single way you
look at it it does not make sense and
it's again just another point of you
wanting to cry about it like why is this
something you're so against many
Societies in the past were poligenous we
are one of the few that are not and this
comes from Roman uh not Greco-Roman
pardon me um uh judeo-christian value
this comes from Christian value so
you're basically just comparing one
religion to another
hmm they're not your beliefs you were
taught this growing up
um
so have you that was amazing and before
we jump into it do either of you uh want
to talk about hijab I know that Judd you
spoke a lot about hijab in the video but
they didn't really put all of it in
um this whole notion that like hijab is
impressive to women like where do they
get this from 100 I mean this is
something that I even addressed
obviously I addressed in the first video
and I think obviously now uh people are
starting to understand more than hijab
isn't really oppressive to woman is to
protect our woman it's to
um
to make sure that everyone obviously
both men and women are are being modest
and just like I think Harmony said that
she was saying like I want it but what
she said basically what she meant is
like this is the reason that hijab is
for all women is that you're seeing the
woman's intellect and you're seeing them
for who they are as a person rather than
seeing them as an object right so that's
the reason for the hijab the hijab is
put in place for us to see a woman for
for her mind and for her intellect and
for who she is as a person rather than
seeing her as just who she is physically
you know what I'm saying so that's
that's obviously one of the many reasons
that the hijab
for a woman is what it is and even Janet
will go back in the video later on
she'll she'll bring it up again in
regards to why she's like why don't men
wear a headscarf she'll bring it up
later on in another topic or something
it's like where we just explained to you
that men have a different hijab than
women how are we gonna have the same
hijab before two completely different
people like two completely different
bodies two completely different
everything how would you expect the same
exact thing to be applied to both of us
it just doesn't matter right and though
they'll always put it on men and women
like the last one was do good should
good Muslim women wear that hijab I
think Jubilee titled that this one when
we did the casting and we applied for
the audition it was Muslims versus
ex-muslims you look at the video this
morning bro the title says uh are men
and women equal in Islam or something
like that wasn't even that it wasn't
even like one of the bigger topics it
was like yeah I was like what bro and
and they they all seem to think like
Islam will force you to wear hijab first
of Allah says there's no compulsion and
deem and when you look at hijab there's
never been a single mention of like dude
like a worldly punishment for hijab you
won't find that a woman disobeying the
Commandments to wear hijab is this
obeying Allah but there's no like Dunya
punishment for it sure countries have
different laws that's fine I agree with
that but there's no islamically
prescribed Sharia punishment for not
wearing hijab you not wearing hijab is
the equivalent of let's say for example
you lying right so you're sinning and
transgressing against yourself and
you're sitting in the eyes of Allah but
there is no Force there's no compulsion
you can wear what you want but I would
even argue like why should a woman be so
oppressed and subjected and subdued to
the point where she has to walk around
as a sex object like why is that always
like how do you how do you call it
oppressive that a woman is wearing hijab
and she's protecting her modesty I find
it oppressive that you guys are using
these women to push all these
advertising in this marketing that's
what I find impressive I find it
impressive that you're using these women
to push out your products and you're
putting their bodies out there and
you're minimizing them down to just
their bodies that's what I find
impressive like how do you call like how
do you not find that the woman like
protecting them and and protecting their
modesty how is that oppressive in
comparison to using these women just for
their bodies which one is more
oppressive
yeah I'm 100 at the same time they'll
promote of as if it's something that's
liberating and you know get your bag and
whatever and like let me ask the sisters
who agree with Janet and Taha and these
these liberal people let me ask you one
question why don't you like why are you
okay with there being a Prohibition on
you walking out naked like why are you
okay with people stopping you from
walking out naked or close to it in the
streets in the malls and the schools and
whatever
are why are you okay with that it's
because you grew up in a society where
it's not normal to do that and they have
a specific standard on what you should
and shouldn't cover
and people as human beings have
different standards there will be women
who look at other women and be like damn
she's wearing a freaking skimpy outfit I
don't know how she's wearing that I
would never
so even in your Society it fluctuates
between people
so how come when we have a standard
that's above all of yours because let's
be frank the West is incredibly immodest
look at like the beaches like 60 years
ago women were fully covered there
were they oppressed or were they happy
to be at the beach you know I'm not
actually saying go look at it but if
you're a sister then go look at it
there's no problem and don't you know
just take my word for inshallah
but regardless
like it's just a different standard
again and again you can look at the
practicality this a hijab will Preserve
modesty between men and women because
for a man the most important thing is
how attractive the woman is especially
in the initial stages so if he sees less
Beauty he'll be less attracted and I'm
not saying that he'll be enticed to go
and like harass a woman I mean he'll be
less enticed to go and flirt with her
encourage her to do Xeno with him and
all the mess that comes about afterwards
this preserves marriages as well because
she's more covered this is less likely
to happen there are so many like wisdoms
behind it that you can extract if you
think about it without any subjective
bias for just like five seconds you can
extract these with no problem but
obviously you just want to take these
points that have been perpetuated by the
West time and time again to yell and cry
against Islam and it's at this point
honestly it's pathetic
topic
reducing women to the sole purpose of
reproduction I don't think it's that men
you know you can impregnate someone
every day and women you know we kind of
have to stay pregnant for a while and I
feel like there would be like a mix-up
with fraternities
like like if it was just one one man
impregnating a bunch of women you could
have a society still I understand what
you're saying but these are such narrow
like what about Islams these are such a
narrow circuits
I'm sorry I want to hear from attia and
Janet as well yeah I think
um also it's just so funny I can guess
the answer
it's just like let us talk bro if that's
like if they have something of value to
say let them come up and say themselves
are you forcing them to say it
yeah I mean it's funny as soon like they
say you can disagree and then as soon as
you disagree they cut you off and let
them know it's so pathetic well little
girl why don't y'all wear a hijab like
why why can't men wear hitches
and once again we already said that
hijab for men and women I'm sorry I
don't want to be that guy do you look at
how like dumb she felt in that moment
not trying to be rude to her but like my
point is they are so incredulous that
they know when they get caught they
don't care they just want to keep like
pestering us about this because we're
both created physically different so
obviously the hijab for both of them
that statement and then once again
you're implying that the hijab is
oppressive to women so that's what
you're implying when you're saying that
why can't men do it because uh
um in the deepest depths of my soul yes
I understand it can be a choice are you
agreeing that or by you saying that the
hijab is oppressive to women that's
actually disrespectful to our women in
the religion because you're either
implying that these women can't think
for themselves and that they're just
wearing this hijab because no I think or
you're saying that we're all forcing
every single woman in the religion to
wear this and we're throwing this
so these justifications that we're
seeing for hijab do these justifications
really still have Solid Ground when we
consider that the hijab was for only one
class of women free woman slave woman
didn't wear hijab and because men were
allowed to have sex with uh with slave
women they were being sexualized and
objectified when Muslim men were
considering whether they're going to
purchase them yeah let me answer that so
to address your slavery point I'll get
on that in a sec all right but the point
that you're asking if we're really equal
how could that be and you were asking if
we all had hijab why do you have to
cover your head with him and I don't
right a very simple example is if I
expect a man and a woman to lift a heavy
load but the same load that would be
unequal right so we have to look at is
it equality or Equity so what is equal
in the eyes of Allah for a man is not
going to be the same treatment for a
woman and I'm sure we understand that if
there are differences in our sex then
there has to be difference in
expectations maybe historically but we
live in a time where a lot of what
you're saying just isn't relevant so
you're not going to be found in a
situation thank you um I would love to
wrap this
if the women would wrap it up okay what
pause
and like in the in the previous video it
was not done like this like we like okay
maybe you should be like can you please
like make sure you say something before
this thing ends because you haven't said
anything but it was never like that
blatant where it's like
it's like yo we need like the woman to
end this like like well come on like
it's just so frustrating yeah I wanted
to I wanted to add a point to the
and this is just something that I'm
gonna throw you out not right now but
when the that brother that's fully
covered probably in more correct hijab
than anyone here
um when he goes on to say something I
have something to say because I've been
in contact with the brother since then
and uh there's there's some good news
inshallah that I want to throw in there
in a bit
so that's great to hear and um
yeah I'm so what let's let the women
finish listen you want to talk about how
women are oppressed and you need to come
stand up for them men men stop your your
male privilege let the women they're
like why do you need to come in and save
them if we're so equal why can't they
just come and jump in and save
themselves and it's so clear there's
still the agenda guys let the women
finish shut up
I'm gonna finish my point like why do
you have a problem with that these
people are so incredulous it's crazy
more people more of um
mm-hmm you'll I'll point it out when it
comes up inshallah you'll also notice
that
they they didn't even let fight address
like the whole slavery thing they let
him just slip it in and then here's the
thing so I'm not gonna post screenshots
obviously for sake of just other common
decency and respect but I've you know
when the video came out today that
brother the one named kafir for
anonymous purposes the one that was
fully covered that ex-muslim
I got a message from him in the morning
and he was like bro did you see that
part where you address the slavery thing
and they didn't even put your response
like they completely edited the photo he
himself messaged me today this morning
on Discord asking if I saw that like
wallahi that blew my mind he was by the
way like he was
he actually was like
and he was the only one using like kind
of at least a little bit of like logical
arguments you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah yeah and you understood at least he
was saying he wasn't just like saying
stuff just to say stuff he genuinely
just didn't understand certain things
and he just wanted to get them addressed
which is 100 okay yeah like but people
they're not they don't actually care to
learn or anything like that or care to
they're just saying stuff to say stuff
yeah so so subhanallah like and he he's
a very genuine guy you know so after the
the whole podcast went down I actually
spoke to him after and I spoke to
one-on-one just for a little bit we
exchanged you know contact information
and I told him that you know I'd love to
talk to you more and or even possibly
host you on the channel and we can talk
about some of the things that we didn't
get to talk about because we didn't get
that time to discuss all the slavery
points and stuff like that and for many
of the viewers watching like there are
there is a big demographic of people
that dedicate their entire livelihood to
having channels that purport
misinformation about Islam unfortunately
and that's why we're making these videos
to clear these misconceptions at the end
of the day because if they have these
misconceptions they get paid they get
more people to hate Islam and
fear-mongering and all this and at the
end of the day it's not just because we
do firmly believe that Islam is the
truth so it deserves for us to give it
that Limelight to at least share Real
Islam with you guys
100 percent
in shot later on I just want to get back
to it let's go
rooted in when it comes to covering up
for example and if you are dressed in
modestly they might react a certain way
they're attracted to your voice I just
have to say I'm a lesbian and I am not
tempted by like in my mind I don't see a
woman walking down the street modestly
and it's not rooted anymore
is it on the screen
I see it on the screen are you sneaking
on the screen oh there yeah oh there you
go okay perfect
both when men and women is equal and I
don't hear that honestly at all
thank you I have lost relationships
I'm about to say one thing and they'll
say no no shut up
the relationships that I've lost would
be relationships that I probably
shouldn't have been in in the first
place once I became more strong in my
faith I had to cut those people off so
those only relationships that I've lost
yes it hurt maybe at the time but I look
at it from the outside perspective that
was the decision that had to make a
relationship that I've lost is in a
different sense than losing contact with
them but the relationship I lost to them
is that I'm unable to be my true self
around them and that relationship is
with my mother and it's the reason why
I'm in this ridiculous outfit today
because
if my mother ever found out that her
only child is going to go to hell
forever because he left Islam it's gonna
hurt her so badly I saw myself how much
it hurt my mom when I was talking openly
about my uh dousin Islam in high school
it was causing her like literal
depression the reason I continued to
pretend and like I don't really have The
Bravery to come out and be my true self
around her is because she's the best mom
I could have ever asked for she did she
worked so hard to raise me she
sacrificed so much to give me a really
happy childhood and the idea that I will
be showing her that all her hard work
was for nothing because her child is
going to burn in hell forever I can't
hurt her like that again like I heard
her in the past she doesn't deserve to
be her she deserves to be happy
I would say I haven't lost any
relationships as far as like dating and
I have no contact with my family but
it's actually not because of the
difference in religions because of a
plethora of other things
um I would say I went to that Islamic
Academy growing up and ironically it was
the best years of my life I had the best
friends when I went to a secular swamp
from a conservative area so I was the
only Iranian so they were bullying me
for being hairy and then when I went to
the Islamic Academy I didn't have that
problem anymore it wasn't until when I
went to high school and I'm sensing
myself from Islam that a lot of people
from our local community
um just kind of like there's Whispers of
oh Janet's families Hypocrites she's a
because I don't dress modestly as
modestly as they'd like me to
um etc etc
um I've lost a lot of I would say my
Muslim friends from the school Islamic
views on homosexuality are outdated
all right this one here we go
oh get your popcorn bro all of them so I
grew up in a pretty queer family my
South Asian family is very uh Muslim
yeah stories
in that environment and all three of
them turned out to be queer I'm queer my
sister's queer it was a long journey
no that's literally called grooming bro
who we are and who we've always been
when I when I look at my grandfather he
and I have strikingly similar stories he
admits that in his village it was normal
for men before they were married to play
around with each other to have
boyfriends
um uh to experiment but then after you
were an adult after you kind of after
you married of course that was off the
table but I I kind of see you know
almost 70 years apart me and him both
have the same stories early 20s got to
experiment with my sexuality you know
now in a long-term relationship with a
girl and and very secure in that but uh
his experience was filled with shame
that that he then passed on to his
daughters so uh I just I see that and I
feel bad for generations of of queer
people who have been uh told that they
can't be
um or that maybe they can be but they
can't act upon it because that is Haram
in some way so queerness is in our blood
it's in our nature it's across species
it's across time it's across history and
uh religion through Islam through
Christianity
um and through various other means um
have been used as tools to erase that
queer history I agree all Abraham all
religion in general organized religion
you're gonna find it I have to I have to
expose this point right now
um I spoke to this brother after
obviously after after the Jubilee uh you
know debate so it was technically in
public property outside
um and then I was speaking to him and I
asked him I was like bro you're not
really an ex-muslim are you
because you said your your dad was a Jew
so you have Jew half Christian wondering
where is his Muslim background I I I
literally asked him I was like you're
not really Muslim are you he looked me
dead in the eyes and he's like no I'm
not
and he didn't finish right there he said
I told them that I wasn't
but they gave me the role anyway bro
what the heck
in the video he doesn't say anything
about like having Islamic beliefs prior
like at no point does he ever talk about
like
being a Muslim
yeah ever that's pathetic that's
actually insanely pathetic from Jubilee
like I I guarantee during the interview
they asked for a story he mentioned how
queer he was and his family is and I I
promise they accepted him just for that
and probably a few other points yeah I
remember Jad even asked him like have
you ever read the Quran he's like no I
haven't and John's like bro I recommend
that you should
you've never read the Quran in your life
and you're given this role of an
ex-muslim like it doesn't make sense bro
to me but let's keep watching before we
get back into it let's let's just
establish what does ex-muslim mean it
means they were a Muslim meaning
presumably they under and Islam and for
some intellectual logical rational
reason decided to leave it that's what
ex-muslim should mean or at least what
people presuppose means when they say uh
I'm an excellent summer when they hear
someone say I'm an ex-muslim here we
have a guy who's never been a Muslim in
his life has never read the Quran who
probably doesn't know the basic
fundamental six pillars of a man five
pillars of Islam uh levels of Islam and
he's on here disagreeing and debating
with Muslims as a fake ex-muslim not
that he did it himself or he wanted to
or whatever but Jubilee allowed such a
person on their show knowing this
according to his own testimony like that
that's extremely pathetic and again
shows they have an agenda against them I
actually hope Jubilee goes down for this
bro like this is actually disgusting
and we'll keep watching bro it gets
worse yeah well sorry one more thing I
want to mention while I bring it up
these
like this guy I think just proved that
it's not something you're born with it's
not something that you just you know
have biologically or whatever and that
is conditioning because the theme is
like 70 years you know worth of
generations of people from his
grandfather down to his you know his his
father and down to him and whatever
there's a reason there a family tree of
queer which he never defined what does
that mean like that you're bisexual like
what does it mean queerness but
regardless like it just shows that it's
conditioning he grew up in a certain
Society doing different things and then
passed it down pass it down and you did
the same exact thing which means
inversely if you lived in an Islamic
Society where there wasn't these uh
disgusting like you know uh corn and all
this uh exploitation uh I don't want to
say the word to get demonetized but you
know all the all these horrible types of
expectation exploitations uh you would
be less likely to uh be attracted to the
same sex you would be more likely to be
attracted to the opposite sex
um like you find in all of you know
Islamic history you don't have too many
people who are eunuchs or who are
attracted to the same size or anything
like that facts absolutely bro
all right I'm pulling it up I think it's
good for us to take small like
intermissions where no one's talking
just to make sure we get everything like
on track yeah and the points that you
mentioned these are important
contentions that a lot of people fail to
see because I want you to understand
anytime that you guys listen to
something from mainstream media and I
will group this platform in with
mainstream media that there is a lot of
censorship and there is a lot of bias
and they will purport the narrative that
they want to purport it's not always
going to be objectively unbiased it goes
without saying so I don't know man like
I feel like in the irony is it's called
middle ground but we'll keep watching
not you're going to find it in
Christianity and Judaism
um I I myself I'm a lesbian I didn't
come out until I was older like an adult
but a lot of that was rooted because I
have such a devout Muslim family it's
like it's if I come out like my mind's
going many places it's not just gonna be
like a normal American family coming out
like I have very abrasive Muslim dad I
don't really see my gayness coinciding
with um religion like an organized
religion I think that Islam has no moral
standing to say that two consenting
queer adults can't be in love while
allowing a man to have sexual
relationships with his slave okay
that is okay but yeah let's let's talk
about this bro because this is this is
something that a lot of people are
spreading misinformation in the comment
section in the Jubilee video about you
know slaves and stuff like that so let's
let's discuss it so in Islam I want you
guys to understand that we don't have
slavery in the sense of Western slavery
and Islam definitely did not create
slavery slavery has always existed
historically speaking Islam name as a
matter of fact believe it or not to
actually end the slavery the Western
definition of slavery which is taking
Free People innocent people and making
them slaves I.E even when they're born
into it by their parents who were slaves
as well they're born into slavery so
Islam came to actually end that version
of slavery what Islam does have are War
captive so in strategic Wars by the way
and we're not we don't just you know
attack innocent people obviously
in these settings when we won the war
there's going to be a bunch of men and
women that are left over right leaving
them free historically speaking other
civilizations would just completely
abolish them we're not going to do that
so what we do instead is we give them
the chance to continue to live but we
take them in they eat from the same food
that we eat from they're clothed by the
same food they were clothed from they
live under the same roof as this bro
they have so much rights to the point
where they can even go to a Sharia court
and they can even
I guess demand to be set free if they
don't like to be with us and Allah even
says in the Quran that that fee that
they have to pay to basically be set
free were encouraged to pay that for our
slaves or I guess captives as well so if
you really think about it this is the
most just form of what happens after a
war than any other solution that you
have in society now obviously if you
have a woman Allah he doesn't categorize
this as Xena or just you know immoral
intercourse and obviously it has to be
consensual too I don't know why people
make the grape argument with consensual
intimacy between a man and a woman that
he has that he's taken care of because
at the end of the day I think it was he
mentioned that the punishment for you uh
graping your you know the female captive
is going to be the same as adultery as
fornication outside
so I really don't see where the issue
with this is additionally if we beat our
slaves which we shouldn't or were
captives we have to set them free it's
obligatory so I I really don't
understand this bro but it's it's thrown
around this buzzword of like slaves and
it makes Islam look bad but when you
really study it you understand that it's
not bad at all it's the most just former
society and a lot of people will also
ask why did Islam not abolish slavery
completely well just like Rami said
Islam is a perfect and succinct way of
life it's a complete way of life it's a
Deen right so if slavery was abolished
overnight just imagine what would happen
to civilization in society you'd have
what a million people plus probably
Millions just free overnight
no longer having food on the table no
longer having someone to look after them
prostitution would be back to an
all-time high so it's not feasible for
that so instead the prophet peace be
upon him and Allah came with Islam as a
revealed religion 1400 years ago to kind
of eradicate slavery and encourage us to
free our slaves not just abolish it
completely
yeah 100 that's an amazing point and
then that begs the question what happens
when there's another war and you have to
do something with the people you can't
let them go you can't just off them well
you're gonna have to take them as War
captive so if it was a ball it's
basically saying we can't do anything
with people after a war but there are
people so it doesn't make any sense
there needs to be action taken to
prevent any kind of chaos or destruction
of of of of livelihood of property of
human beings lives and
I was about to jump on the uh the topic
I had here about I'll hold myself for
when we get there but yeah that's an
amazing Point 100 like if you look at
like the cross-atlantic slave trade by
the way when it's like when slavery was
a boss you could read the history on
this you hide a bunch of people who with
with no property no job no livelihood
thrown into the street they don't even
have a house to go to they used to live
with their their owner which I'm not
saying that this was good this system
was disgusting they kidnapped people
from from continent and move them over
uh out of pure racism which was
biblically backed by the way
so like it's absolutely horrendous
disgusting but when they were freed
they were
poor basically on the street and a lot
of them went back to their previous
owners you know basically wanted to be
taken back
and it's horrendous on its side but you
know Islam would not allow such a thing
Islam but even if they ended up being
poor someone would still take care of
them the state would still take care of
them that's why we have is a cat that's
why we have jizya that's why we have
systems in place to make sure that no
one is oppressed or taken advantage of
or or suffers under our our control but
yeah and the Jizzy and the Jesus the
Jizzy itself too bro it's literally from
male non-muslim combatants
that they don't have to fight our Wars
for us and that will fight their Wars in
particular of them like it's not even
for non-combans bro so I I really don't
and me and Jeff brought up all these
points and that's why I say all Muslims
learn your religion and study your
religion and and give dawah because at
the end of the day me and Jad have
either number one set these points
number two
didn't get to see these points because
they cut us off or number three didn't
even put them in the actual video you
know they cut out these parts so
unfortunately we have to talk about it
here yeah unfortunately
we do what we must and uh you guys did a
great job have the love for Monica C so
far one last point I want to mention is
where all the all respect to this guy I
don't want to disrespect him based on
what you said he seems like a pretty
fair person
um I I don't think he says Craigslist as
the others but why is he comparing
homosexuality to having sex with a a
female uh servant or a female a war
prisoner how are these two things
comparable he kept breaking it up as
that was just yeah
I think it's I guess ideology was more
so if two people that are same-sex
cannot have intimacy consensually then
why is it okay in Islam for a man to
kind of be with his War captive I.E
insinuating that it's non-consensual but
that's not even the case at all so I
don't understand that I mean
I was gonna say if that was his argument
it should have been clear about that but
what he said specifically is Islam
doesn't have the Moral Moral High Ground
that's what he said it doesn't have the
moral capacity to prohibit this and
allow that but why on what basis what
morality do you have where do you get
the morality from how can you prove that
it is the morality effectively or better
Superior than whatever way and I guess
since we're on the topic
um it would be if a lot allowed a man
and his wife to have like sex then that
I see would see a contradiction in in
some capacity because what do you when
you say almost talking about you're
talking about a man having sex with
another man basically eight likes
essentially
that's basically what you're you're like
celebrating here and it's not even love
because Islam doesn't say you know don't
love another man or anything with the
prohibitions on the actual act itself
so it's it's no longer it's just love
it's not if it was just love you
wouldn't need the sexual act if it was
just like it's not it's actual sexual
immorality but Allah doesn't allow even
a man and a woman to have uh effect so
it's like there's no comparison there
for him let me let me add this point
around me when you said that it's it's
the act so it's it's not the inclination
itself that's wrong no there's there's a
difference in opinion on this but the
majority of Scholars say that the
inclinations especially when they're
uncontrollable is not your fault because
how are you going to be punished for
something that's intrusive or something
that is out of your circle of control
just you thinking that you're gay but
the problem is the act that you
mentioned right
in Islam you need four male Witnesses
adult sane mind reliable trustworthy
sober to basically testify that they saw
you having this act with another man
and spying is Haram in Islam so unless
you were completely kind of out there in
the open in just being careless just in
a way where even a kid could just come
by and watch you guys of course that's
going to lead to the spiraling down in
dysfunction of society and that's what
the punishment is for that and even if a
man or woman were doing that there would
be the same punishment
so I don't understand what the problem
with this is it's more so just we're
trying to protect the fabric of society
and decency
I think you should watch this segment
and then
we'll see what happens because when you
when you bring up the incest point and I
bring up the monkey pox Point bro
like this is crazy I hate that they cut
it off
our adults who are in a loving
relationship fully consensual is no
power Dynamic it's bad
my question is if it's okay for two
consensing for example males who have
love for each other to conduct sexual
intercourse then what is the problem
with two brothers who have love for each
other and they're consenting
insistent you're comparing homosexuality
please
long just keep
I want you to just track I don't know if
you kept the whole thing in this track
how long it takes until like
just notice how none of them actually
say anything the first point they'll
ever be able to bring will be brought up
by the girl sitting next to me in
harmony she's the one that actually
gives them an out and they all jump on
it but before she says anything they all
have no answer to this question just
keep watching it
okay because they both come from the
same point there's two people who
consent to having sex together
what is the problem with them if they
both consent and they both have love for
each other just like two males who don't
know which one for each other
you just did this thing in public
speaking
do you notice he has he knows that I'm
spitting and he doesn't want me to keep
talking so he said and he sees that
another girl that has a more liberal
mindset wants to speak he said let her
please put the let her speak right now
and he knows that she's on her side
because she already disagreed with me
earlier on this right so now she's gonna
now she's gonna speak and now it's
literally me against the four of them
and this girl like is just like you're
talking about the liberal Muslim
you're going to continue to notice that
she like she disagreed with me probably
more than she agreed with me for the
majority yeah she she came at me and she
had more than yeah yeah she came at the
other ones yeah they they handicapped
you guys bro with her and that's pretty
messed up that's what one of the
funniest comments I saw it on me was
someone wrote alhamdulillah Brothers
fight and Chad held it down in that 2v6
everyone tell me that everyone that I
talked to that watched the video said
literally it was a 2v6 I was like yeah
yeah Jubilee you guys sucked to be
honest you guys suck the game called
minimizing our issue and then you're
trying to find this correlation
addressing the principle which is coming
from objective morality so I'm trying to
figure out that's what I'm trying to
figure out okay if this is wrong if
homosexuality is okay then what makes
incest not okay let me tell you let me
say what's bringing up is not relevant
it is
not relevant tell me why it's not
relevant yeah that's all I'm asking you
for tell me why it's not relevant all I
keep saying is it's not relevant it's
not relevant I mean I'm telling you how
it's relevant why can't you respond
like tell me why it's not relevant and
then you're gonna see Harmony right now
she's gonna bring up the power Dynamic
point and they're just gonna
eat that up because they finally found
an out that they can use
but before she said that like
they literally had no answer whatsoever
even the power Dynamic argument I'll
wait till she says it and then I'll talk
all right
socialization what is the problem with
them if they both consenting and they
both have love for each other just like
two males who don't know each other for
each other what is the problem I just
want to say you just did this thing in
public speaking called minimizing our
issues
which is coming from objective morality
so I'm trying to figure out that's what
I'm trying to figure out if this is
wrong if homosexuality is okay then what
makes incest not okay well let me tell
you let me say what you are bringing up
is not relevant it is not it has nothing
to do
who are not related has everything to do
we're not on the same place
I'll let you all speak every single time
what's wrong with two brothers
yes please please okay so I feel like
incest is wrong because one if you have
a child with this person there might be
something wrong with it not to mention
that if somebody has known you since you
were born the influence that they'll
have over your life is different than if
you made the choice to actually be with
them that's why it's wrong here's the
thing about
homosexuality because you would think
that I'm homophobic because you know
like I guess everybody assumes I'm like
extra Pious and whatever because I cover
my face right actually one of my parents
um is a member of the LGBT community I
grew up with some cousins that were I
had friends that were all throughout
elementary school and high school and
stuff I never saw
um
morally something wrong with it I think
that the reason that it was put into
Quran is simply about sustainability you
can't sustain life on Earth if people
like the majority of the population I
don't think it would say that anybody's
better than anybody else you have the
capacity for her love we all just want
to love and be loved she's a river at
the end of the day with all this work
with all due respect but at the end of
the day we can't just make reasons up
you know according to whims and desires
and why Allah has the wisdom that he has
portrayed to us so you can't say it's
because of all continuation of species
so if you know gayness was rampant then
you know men and women would not have
intimacy we would not have kids in a
generations and populations would not
increase
says who sure you could say that's
probably your hypothesis but you can't
just say that at the end of the day
there's far more things happening in the
Unseen bro in the spiritual that we're
not even aware of that we can't even
comprehend there's a lot of things that
if even if Allah revealed them to us we
would not comprehend them at all so
let's not limit ourselves to
one-dimensional thinking that's all I
have to say and rum is what I was
talking about in terms of when they hear
something that doesn't really
necessarily go against them notice how
when I was speaking you could barely
hear me get a word out but when she
starts speaking everyone is quiet right
yeah it's pathetic It's like because
like they they can always interrogate
but they cannot be interrogated and even
what she said like
um if you mentioned a point about if you
if you grew up with someone they're
gonna have a lot more influence that
doesn't you one that doesn't make any
sense because like so what if you grew
up with someone like does that mean if
you have a you can have a so if you met
a girl in um Elementary School that you
that you liked you want to marry her
later on in life you can't marry her
because you knew her in elementary
school exactly right and and wouldn't
you what do you not have equal influence
over each other because you've known
each other for the same amount of time
or your whole life like it literally
doesn't make any sense there's a power
dynamic in every relationship like
there's just like it's almost bigger
than someone else yeah fine fine two men
in a relationship the one is like the
dumb one is a sub that's literally just
human nature every relationship every
relationship is gonna have that yeah 100
and like what if you have like two
people who are biologically related
brother and brother who just didn't know
each other and then by the way wait wait
play it play a video let's do it it
brings up that point bro let me play it
oh my God is the idea there's two
consenting individuals that want to have
sexual inter course regardless of their
backgrounds what is wrong with that
because we don't we're not saying that
that's the only determiner here we're
saying between two men who have not
grown up together who are not brother or
brother and brother so it's two
different things they are two different
okay so let's say there's two estranged
brothers that never grew up together can
we pause I would like to hear uh Jack
you can make a final statement I'd like
to hear from you
um
listen
my witness and Allah is my witness that
well why after this point when I said
when I said that point the two estranged
Brothers if there's two estranged
brothers that and they meet and they
want to have sexual intercourse is that
okay he said he said yes said yes and
they cut it out really yes he agreed he
said he said yes there's nothing wrong
with that in my opinion but they didn't
put it in go back just rewind yeah look
at him say look at him say he says
honestly
honestly only determiner here we're
saying
are not brother and brother so it's two
different things they are two different
okay so let's say there's two estrangers
brothers that never grows
there's no way to include that in the
video because it will completely
obliterate them oh my God I can't put
that in the video that's pathetic and
you know the worst part is they could
have all just said yeah there's no
problem with it
well like what do you say after okay
you're so morally and and and
psychologically regressed that you think
that's okay wow you guys are really
weird like that's like
yeah
it would have been more beneficial to
them it would have been more beneficial
to them to just say that it's okay yeah
yeah yeah they were disgusting man
honestly this is Jubilee like you guys
are filthy like honestly the way or
maybe not as a whole organization but
whoever conducted this clearly has an
agenda and and whoever edited it as well
and I think that that is disingenuous
it's disgusting alhamdulillah I'm glad
that you know I have the honor of being
with the brothers so they can clear it
up to everyone
final statement I'd like to hear from
Atia um and can we keep it about
homosexuality so that's close up incest
you want to bring up the point about how
you can you not have homosexual
incestors obviously I'm sorry pause it
please please please please I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry that was the
probably the most moronic thing I've
ever heard and this is because this
woman is lucky she's behind the camera
she's lucky she's behind the camera we
don't we can't see who she is so she
doesn't have embarrassment of going out
in public after saying something so uh
uh ignorant you cannot have homosexual
incest is that impossible
a man and a man who happened to be
brothers that's that's not a logical
possibility all of a sudden it hasn't
been done before it's a new thing that
we invented after this recording that
you guys did
this is actually so pathetically
disingenuous I wish you would have
brought herself and pulled up a bench
inside because she wanted to talk so
much it's actually pathetic and and it's
just like clean up making about incest
that's what the the end of the day the
argument isn't about instance it's not
about homosexuality it's about objective
morality and what is determining what is
okay and what's not and they didn't want
to address that they didn't want to
address that
I asked them you saw me as I asked a
thousand times why is it not okay and
before it uh harmony put the idea of the
power Dynamic into their head there was
no answer there was no he couldn't tell
me why it's not relevant all he could
say is it's not relevant it's not
relevant it's not relevant when I'm
proving to him why it's relevant
hmm yeah
has been proven to come from homosexual
intercourse and a man
um all the STDs yeah
it's been scientifically proven that
STDs are more in homosexual
relationships heterosexual people get
STDs too so your arguments
there's new STDs that are resulting from
this type of intercourse that's
happening and it's found along
yeah a very recent size
why is she go you're oh my God why are
you arguing with me listen listen listen
homosexual people are that's why it's
hard there's new sdds that are resulting
from this type of intercourse that's
happening
yeah a very recent scientifically proven
one was monkey pox that the overwhelming
literature
you're projecting a stereotype it
literally became a stereotype against
gay men How is scientific literature a
stereotype
you have clearly believed all of the
Google articles about how it was only
attributed to the gay community that's
my opinion that's it
monkeypox was ridiculous my personal
desires
I'm pretty sure one of you might want to
jump and move for me so I'll give you
guys the the room
how was scientific primary peer-reviewed
literature
in established journalism today ever
just
what
um if you go on on government like World
Health Organization websites they will
say that homosexual sex produces a seven
times higher likelihood of Contracting
an STD or STI seven times more likely
and also anal sex you're more likely to
contract something
um a hardness as well which Again by the
way news flash is prohibited in Islam so
like if you can't connect the dots or
even begin to connect the dots you
either have a crazy advice you're not
even willing to think on this topic but
the fact that she just like she it's
funny she mentioned before that you did
this debate tactic she did a debate
tactic I don't know what it's called we
see every day in reality where they're
like are you serious really you really
think that they just try and make you
look stupid or silly like how could you
believe that they put you in this box of
you're a little dummy and uh also no one
has to listen to you it's pathetic and
ugly just to be honest hmm
I think I had to I said what I had to
say on this especially in the video is
pretty transparent in terms of
like it's pretty obvious like if you
have if you're going into it in a nun in
a non-bias POV
um it's pretty obvious that like
what the situation is so
this is the last question
it's ridiculous my personal desires do
not have a place in Islamic faith
I look like I'm praying in the back for
me other than like the obvious I'm part
of the LGBT another thing that I I just
want to quickly just quickly get out
there
they could not even pay us bro
for our flights
early accommodations yes and and the
best part is they have a patreon
really they literally took parts of our
four-hour conversation some prompts and
they only release it on patreon you will
not even see that on YouTube for free
for the general public to see so they
profited hella off of us and they
couldn't even just give us
flights or anything so that's
questioning I want to ask you guys a
question you two because I didn't watch
the full video
um I've only seen basically what we
watched together did they ask anything
that's in favor of Muslims and in
disfavor of the ex-muslims not
necessarily in favor there was stuff
that there was things that like we
completely agreed on like us on the
other side I guess in terms of there was
no contention because it was so obvious
like
um the one that they put on the patreon
I think right yeah one of them another
one we joked on some jokes like for
example we all grew up uh not allowed to
eat pork like all eight of us yeah yeah
it's just something I mean I can't
remember all the problems to be honest
there was there was probably they
probably cut out like three or four yeah
but why couldn't they put any
any any uh prompts against the
ex-muslims like all ex-muslims are
emotional or they only leave for
emotional or something that's against
them why is everything about
homosexuality or you know Muslims are
too strict or Muslims can't get with the
program
families have changed we're better
nowadays why like that's so hypocritical
and completely disingenuous you know
that brother the one with the pseudonym
kaffir covered up he told me after the
debate word for word
that why did they not give us
opportunities to talk about the things
that we like about Islam and I was like
what do you mean and he's like I still
love the charity aspect of Islam I still
love that it's selfless
they didn't even ask us these things I
was excited do you really think they
would
wow may Allah got him back to his time
he actually seems from what I hear like
a very kind-hearted person 100 man he
was he was for sure but something
just so you have an idea of the people
that me and Fayed were trying to work
with here a couple different things Atia
attia was in the last video that I was
in the Liberals versus uh conservative
Muslims quote unquote
um attia was actually supposed to be in
that video she was on the set but one of
the conservative Muslims didn't show up
so they had to drop one of the liberal
Muslims and she was the one that got
dropped from the liberal side so it's
crazy to damn she was a liberal Muslim
it's crazy to think this was gonna be
someone that I was going to be against
that they were on my side for this video
so it's something crazy to think about
and another thing to think about is the
fact that which this is this absolutely
blew my mind that after the recording
Romney they
they were like Atia and I think Nat or
um Harmony and then everyone from the
other side they went to go get lunch
together
how could you how could you go get lunch
with someone who
this believes
not like not that I wouldn't go get
lunch with one of my friends that's not
Muslim but in terms of someone who left
their religion and just argued with you
about why leaving the religion is okay
how can you go get lunch with them after
arguing with them for four hours that to
me that absolutely blew my mind yeah
especially over the Muslims you know
like I'm not saying that like there are
women something they should have gone
out with you guys to eat or anything but
like especially over the Muslims it's
like Allah specifically says in the
Quran do not take the uh the non-muslims
as protectors over the Muslims and
they're agreeing with the non-muslims
they basically they are like the
non-muslims they're like Muslims the
kuffar and uh they're siding with them
and protecting them essentially as well
they're going a step further they're not
being protected by them they're
protecting them I said I probably never
I'm gonna do this again just because of
it is a very frustrating experience and
stress
um is enough but um
um
it's about at least a lot at least
people knowing that it's important for
us regardless of how badly we're going
to be represented or how badly they're
going to cut it up and whatever agenda
they're trying to push regardless as
long as like the people who actually
understand the faith and understand
Islam and are looking at this from a
non-biased point of view can I actually
see that like it's very very obvious
when you're looking at this from a
non-biased point of view like where
things are standing and I think it's
important for us to have Muslims who are
knowledgeable on their D not saying that
I'm I'm not nowhere near as
knowledgeable as I want to be where I
need to be but I have at least that
understanding of of Islam um it's
important to have these people
representing Islam rather than because
if you look at prior to these last two
videos that I was in the Muslim
representation that was on Jubilee it's
it's like it's not it's non-existent
it's people that you like the best the
best of them maybe pay five times a day
so you know it's just like
I think we should continue to put out
their Muslims who are genuinely on their
faith and I want to be better Muslims
and people who know a little bit about
Islam and are actually practicing rather
than just putting anyone that's labeled
himself a Muslim and just put them on
this video so they can get a little bit
of clout yeah Judd is crazy that we
generally didn't really even want to go
but we kept talking with each other
about if not us then who like that was
right this one I genuinely I didn't I
didn't want to I really didn't want to
go to this but
especially I understood how how
difficult the conversation was going to
be and I'd rather I'd rather like I'm
confident in myself enough that I'd
rather have me and fayad there and
obviously I'm confident fayad that we
can like I'm confident what we'll bring
and I'd rather not jeopardize or like
take the bet on on other people that I
don't have no idea who's gonna go and
represent our Dean yeah
oh there's more
yeah this is a little bit more I was
just gonna say that
um like everyone who watched ask
yourself the question if you took any of
those uh like the the two Muslims that
were on your guys's side or the four
ex-muslims on the other side and put
them in a one-on-one debate live no like
no Cuts just one-on-one no director to
stop anyone from talking with either
fight or Judd who would win in that
debate or discussion I think it's clear
based on this video who would win
because one side was actually prepared
and brought arguments and tried to make
logical and rational points the other
side just literally for lack of better
word just cried the whole time how dare
you believe this how could you believe
this I I believe this that's all I'm
gonna say that's not good enough you
don't get the right to interact me and
then sit here and say think what you
believe I don't I don't really care
about your beliefs frankly
hmm
subhanallah you're right bro let's go
back to it
man you look hella just posted up bro I
love him about it just chilling I'm
relaxed man I have to sit back to relax
myself
just guys context y'all probably gonna
see this at noon on Monday it's right
now it's Sunday night it's 11 40 p.m for
me and Jad and it's 12 40 a.m so y'all
better smash this like button on the
Stream
it's Muslim and I felt like I didn't
have decisions or a choices growing up
and when it came to Islam I remember I
questioned things in my religion class I
remember like the Imam told me like
women when you go to Hajj you can't wear
um like body spray right or perfume I
raised my hand during
um my religious class and I asked why
and I always got met with well because
the Quran says so like be quiet Janet's
a problematic kid asking me questions
um I just feel like there's no room
really there even without the LGBT
community
okay quick disclaimer don't want to go
on too long of a tension on the side but
when you're in ekram the state when
you're performing or Hajj men and women
both together we cannot wear scented
stuff like soaps and deodorants and
stuff it's not just women
but I do sympathize with her this whole
Allah knows best or Allah said so this
approach isn't really good for everyone
especially from like a parenting or
teaching point of view so we should take
that responsibility to learn better and
eloquently explain these things better
especially the kids
part of me like what you want kind of it
felt like doesn't matter there's no room
for it it's just it is what it is and
you need to obey it at the end of the
day if you commit a sin and you don't
seek repentance your Allah is going to
punish you for it even if your personal
desires conflict with that because of
that looming threat it does not matter
what you want if it goes against what
Allah says then you are risking having
your bones crushed in the grave or you
are risking having your skin burned off
of your face it doesn't matter how
illogical you think it is if you believe
in Islam and Allah says it's bad and you
go against that you are putting yourself
in a huge risk of a lot of pain and
suffering
I think
buyers because it because it does it
just doesn't have room for our
compulsions and I heard this quote
someone said my religion is perfect but
I am not you have to allow Islam to
teach you that you've blurred the lies
between your desires and your
compulsions and the things that you
actually need out of life so it's really
hard to be thankful to God if you're
connected to all these things that are
calling you to pull you different
directions can I see a question yeah
yeah so is your standard for Haram Halal
vary at all how would you base your
standard off of how were you taught
those standards
um I learned them from Quran or for my
upbringing like if I don't know so oh
yeah so I think everything you're saying
is valid and I think you can also
believe all these things even just like
outside of Islam like I think these
principles have existed like throughout
time other religions other philosophy no
they haven't what is this man talking
about and so my question is like when it
comes to the more sort of confusing like
I was raised on a lot of people okay
look how you brought that up like it's
something like so unique that he's not
allowed to eat pork
people who don't pray five times a day
at one point somebody told me that was
because they're not safe to eat or like
you know it's dirty point being
absolutely there are moments like you
can you can definitely live your life
that way but my question is like at what
point do you question those those
nuances those like those confusing
questions first I question why I'm
questioning it it's like why do I want
to have a different answer than what's
written here first I question that and
then I'll do research and I'll say okay
well how will people living like before
my time before my parents before
grandparents and why didn't they choose
to eat this animal well maybe because it
eats its own fecal matter or it eats its
children I mean you know its own fetus
and stuff like that well I understand
what I'm saying is how do you deal with
the logic of it because there's many
ways to argue around it it's quite nice
oh my God yeah he's such a hypocrite bro
why doesn't he ask himself the same
question why is he okay with
homosexuality why does he not ask
himself why am I okay with homosexuality
is there a possibility that's immoral am
I just following the society tells me is
right or wrong he is such a hypocrite
it's crazy he literally just wants to
interrogate question and question any
single Muslim who believes whatever
about Islam and has moral uh standing
and just put them under the category of
their they were raised like this don't
you ever question don't you ever want to
experiment don't you ever think
logically why do you ever ask yourself
where morality even comes from logically
is it objective is it consequential is
it subjective is it relative
if you're such a philosopher on the
subject all of a sudden why don't you
bring up these topics why don't you
discuss it intellectually instead of
just questioning everyone and
interrogating everyone this guy
specifically so I have no respect for
people like this like if he's gonna sit
on some kind of moral High Ground you
have to justify it and it's pathetic
that I sit there questioning everybody
where does your objective morality come
from
it's those people that yeah you're right
bro these people that they don't have
genuine questions they'll ask you a
question and then once you respond
they'll ask you another irrelevant
question and they'll just like they love
mental gymnastics and there's just this
debate bro like it's it's kind of like
one of the tricks and I'm not comparing
these people to a shared team so I don't
want you all to think that I'm
slandering them but that's how shaitan
actually makes us I guess forget Allah
and become heedless with was shaytan
will give you one intrusive thought one
doubt and then when you logically answer
it shaytan will give you another doubt
so it's one of the oldest textbook
tricks of the devil that he gets you to
have one thing after another thing after
another thing and to solve that isn't
necessarily to logically do it because
there's always going to be one more
thing logically that might make you feel
uneasy but it's to understand like where
are all these things coming from and
getting to the root of it why do you
have an issue with these things to begin
with so it's kind of like you know these
women will say for example Islam forces
you to wear hijab I don't want to do
that I want to wear what I want right
but it's like ask yourself this whole
thing that I want where did that even
come from is this generally your choice
or are you conditioned and program by
your surroundings in society and they
kind of brainwashed you to think that
here's what you want what if you're
fitra your predisposed condition without
any other conditioning whatsoever would
actually prefer to be in hijab
yeah that's a great point and I want to
give one example be an amazing point I
want I I need people to understand I
need people to understand imagine there
was a man who used tactics methods
persuasion Society
to try and
uh teach a woman why she should love him
and be with him
it would call that coercion they say
that's disgusting they would say that's
manipulative but all of a sudden when
all of society and the different
Industries
um for retail that uses women as John
was mentioning before even cars car
dealerships and companies will use women
in their in their in their videos for
some reason obviously makeup industry
the corn industry and all these
disgusting Industries they will beautify
women in a specific way that sets a
precedent in a standard for how you
should look in dress and if you don't
you feel out of place how was that not
relation and coercion in the same exact
form and why are you okay with that
showing up dressing how you're dressing
with the makeup that you're wearing
saying what you're actually defending
the same people who coerced you and if a
victim of of a man who chorister was
defending him you would say that this is
some kind of Stockholm where that should
be so lost she doesn't even know she's
being a victim poor girl poor girl you
you women actually are the poor women I
genuinely feel bad for you because you
think that you chose to do this you were
actually coerced into thinking it was
your choice and that's the worst you
know type of manipulation that exists
let's resume this
essentially yeah there's a lot of things
that you may not understand why things
essentially what you're saying is if
something is not allowed and you don't
understand why it's not allowed how do
you kind of go about being okay with
this thing not being allowed if God is
telling us not to do something or to do
something even if we don't understand
the wisdom behind it is the fact that we
know that he's the most knowledgeable so
we trust in the fact that whatever he's
telling us to do or not to do that is
the best thing for us blind loyalty yes
like bro he just described a very
logical line of thinking you have
something that is all knowledgeable that
is all wise
and that is also also all truthful that
will not lie you can trust the answer
they give is perfect
that's Blind Faith he literally
described a logical line of thinking now
whether we have proof for God in our
slam that's a different topic but for
you to assume a mind faith is so
pathetic and disingenuous and it shows
that they're not even on the like they
need to go back to the basics they're
not even on the level to discuss these
these big topics they're questioning all
these big things sometimes and this is
not respectful towards them I don't or I
don't mean for it to be disrespectful
towards them I can't understand Advanced
physics that doesn't mean I go on and
question physics how does how can a
photon be in two places at once how can
a photon travel for the from the Sun and
hit my face instantly at the same time
how does I don't believe this I can't do
that just because I don't understand the
advanced physics doesn't mean thing here
because you don't understand it and
you're questioning it left right and
Center doesn't mean it's wrong maybe you
need to build up a foundation and a
basis to be able to even understand
these things and have a intellectual
discussion about it I think that's the
worst part they brought honestly
probably intellectually speaking the the
worst possible people and that's no
disrespect to them
that's not on I'm sorry listen listen
you guys have to listen no disrespect
towards you guys okay it's Jubilee's
fault they set up
and they had you guys come on that's not
your fault okay
and I love you guys
sorry
let's get back into it bro
you're saying something I'll ask someone
more knowledge and if they can't give me
an answer as to why something is the way
that it is then we believe that Allah
and his Prophet know what's best and at
that point I believe in my faith in God
that's what faith is i i i there's
there's just a small hiccup in both of
your like scientific method here which
is that why don't get me started bro
this man's acting like the scientific
method is like the objective measuring
stick of reality yeah and what Jad said
wasn't even scientific it was not even
scientific
it was deductive
I am I questioning and then then there's
your part if I don't get the right
answer or an answer that makes sense to
me I keep asking I keep asking I keep
asking but if you don't get it then
there's this kind of cognitive
dissonance that now needs to exist I
think I think I think like a good way to
put it is like part of existing as a
human being is questioning everything
that's how we've developed everything
that's how we grow and adapt so I want
to add something really quick I know
that like there's been a lot of
questions with what he said especially
you guys saying like that's Blind Faith
I think that there is like I see your
point but there's a lot of Mary and like
I agree that like meaning of life is
questioning things however if you keep
questioning everything you're going to
have the most doubtful horrible
untrusting life in the entire University
like the goal is like the one time she
actually so I think that like we can
only question some of the things and I
think personally from my questioning I
have found the answers to which that has
led me to trust the God that I believe
in and that is why I also believe in the
other things that he tells me to
subscribe to because I believe that that
is good for me so it's not always that
every Muslim or anybody who subscribes
to religion is like blindly believing in
everything no they they have a trusting
relationship with that form of God or
that religion or that ideology and
therefore they choose to subscribe to
other ideals yeah I totally relate I I
there's a lot of insecurity here
um there's there's a lot of Doubt um
there's a lot of thinking I just I I
think it is a much more difficult and
much more Noble Path to take you know
through the chaos through the unknown
um through the lack of of prescription
through questioning
um rather than just kind of taking the
carrot in the Stick Of Heaven and Hell
and and saying that that's you know
those are my answers and and that brings
me Comfort I I think that there are
paths to being a good human
um outside of religion and I believe
earnestly that those paths are much
harder to take my question to you would
be like where do you draw the line we
all draw the line where bro that's not
even what I asked they cut it off so
decide what is okay and what is not okay
do you guys not see that it would just
be left to individual opinions no I
think there's I think there's like a
pretty base
as a human of
rights necessarily scientific person I'm
going to do my research I have Engineers
for parents so that gives me peace yeah
it's my different kind of piece I don't
think people are just atheists or
non-religious people running rampant
without a set of rules I think just to
be a good person religion aside there's
just pretty standard things and we are
done ladies and gentlemen who determines
what these standard things are that's
exactly what works
it's it's so stupid it's like and bro
like
if I if I were to ask them this question
it wouldn't make it into the Final Cut
but like let's take you know 1939 1940
Germany
like they had their own beliefs their
time their place their relative morality
obviously they didn't all agree but you
know they had that General belief as
human beings they all had a general Leaf
about morality
our general belief about morality is
wrong and the Muslims General belief
about morality is is is so would you say
using this line of thinking that their
beliefs were morally Justified because
they generally believed that at the time
exactly like it's so pathetic and
actually I like the point that the guy
made about uh like the scientific meth
involved whatever whatever Notch taking
the carrot in the stick Islam actually
encourages logical rational thinking it
actually encourages reflecting
reflecting and pondering and questioning
and like where does he think the
scientific method came from it came from
the Muslims and they used ayas from the
Quran like you know Allah asks do they
not look at the Sheik camels and see how
it was constructed that you know makes
you wonder how was it constructed maybe
I can find that out do they not say how
Allah raised the the the sky I forget
the exact wording no in whole sky on
whatever okay maybe we should go look at
how that actually works and the Muslims
did that that's where our algorithms
came from that's where Optics came from
that's where
medicine and all these different uh
sciences that flourish came from the
scientific method as a whole so what he
just described
uh naturally is Islamic
hmm
I mean alhamdulillah I think
that was very what a wonderful point to
end it on
Abdullah yeah I'm sorry guys I know you
were there so you're probably tired of
it I'm just saying it for the first time
someone anger is just like sprouting out
now you guys got a lot of out during
that for our discussion I'm just getting
it out now alhamdulillah but yeah
everyone everyone that's been watching
and everyone everyone that's texting me
and everything is just like bro I don't
know how you guys were so patient I'm so
frustrated watching this yeah yeah I'm
like bro believe me we were boiling
inside when we were there but just you
have to if you if you release that not
to mention when we exited that studio
bro we got an amber alert saying there's
literally a grade five hurricane like
literally literally and we're just like
damn our flights are probably gonna be
canceled too so all in all
10 out of 100 would not recommend you
know bamila Bliss
all the viewers that have benefited from
this inshallah if you did enjoy this
content
please consider using the limited time
that is not guaranteed in our lifespan
to learn as much as we can about Islam
and the truth and to convey from that
even if it's one Ayah as the prophet
Islam says and trust me when I tell you
this the Returns on this are going to be
astronomical in the like just learning
about Islam and sharing it with people
it's so simple and it's so easily
palatable because it's the truth and the
truth isn't something that has to be
convinced it isn't something that has to
be proven it isn't something that has to
be groomed or programmed or conditioned
into you
so understand that we have a very fine
amount of time in this life
spend as much of it as you can keeping
your intentions renewed and learning
Islam and sharing it with people
but if you want to do a little bit extra
support us share this video like
everything that you can inshallah helps
my brothers is there anything that you
guys want to add
yeah I have one announcement I don't
have all the details in alhamdulillah I
think I think it's October 21st I3 is
hosting the arc convention it's an event
for Muslims Mohammed a job is going to
be there Abdullah and Lucy's going to be
there and a bunch of other great
speakers it's going to be here somewhere
in the GTA I believe it's in Mississauga
so stay tuned inshaallah if there is a
link we'll put in the description and
stay tuned for further videos or go to
I3 institute.ca or I3 Institute
Instagram
and I'm going to be there hopefully
fighting on Hill will be as well
inshallah we will see and update you
guys as we go it's about a month away
from now so if we got plenty of time see
you guys there inshallah so number one
anho is alive and healthy Allah it's
just like what 6 a.m from right now
where he is so unfortunately he couldn't
make it on this but number two good news
will be together in an undisclosed
location I'm gonna say we're very soon
inshallah so expect a lot of in-person
videos coming up we're gonna be back on
the channel 2023 we're taking over
inshallah and Jad you always welcome bro
as always for inviting me and allowing
us to speak and it was an honor going in
that video with you and um inshallah it
was of benefit to at least one person
alhamdulillah
[Music]
with that being said
and we will see you on the next one